here are some beautiful words  effervescence  bubbles in a liquid  hereith a longing for a home you can't  return to or that never was  ephemeral  lasting for a very short time  incandescence light produced by high  temperatures  limerence the state of being infatuated  with another person  somnambulist  a person who sleepwalks  sonorus  an imposingly deep and full sound  mellifluous  a sound that is sweet and smooth  pleasing to hear  aurora  dawn  phosphenes the light and colors produced  by rubbing your eyes epic a particular  period of time in history or a person's  life  epiphany a moment of sudden revelation  the act of throwing someone out of a  window  petriker  the pleasant earthy smell after rain  luminescence light produced by chemical  electrical or physiological means  which words do you think are beautiful  bye